[Música]
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski visitó las poblaciones cercanas
a kiev para comprobar los horrores
causados por las tropas rusas occidente
denuncia crímenes de guerra mientras que
moscú dice que se trata de otra puesta
en escena
que francia se acorta la brecha entre
los candidatos de ultraderecha y el
presidente manuel macrón de cara a la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales aunque el mandatario
sigue liderando las encuestas sus
contrincantes conservadores suman un
mayor porcentaje de favorabilidad
nueva alerta sobre los efectos del
cambio climático la onu advirtió que si
continuamos con el ritmo actual el
planeta se calentará 3,2 grados este
siglo esto en medio de los compromisos
de los países para no superar los 1,5
grados
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz se cumple más de un mes de la
invasión rusa a ucrania y el presidente
vladimir putin enfrenta acusaciones de
crímenes de guerra tras los
descubrimientos hechos en una ciudad
recuperada por el ejército ucraniano
butch a donde denuncian haber hallado
fosas comunes de supuestos civiles
asesinados rusia insiste en que todo
hace parte de un montaje andrés
granadillo nos cuenta más el presidente
ucraniano revivir el tour visitó mucha y
denunció que la cifra de muertes puede
ser mayor
estos son crímenes de guerra y serán
reconocidos por el mundo como genocidio
ustedes están aquí pueden ver lo que
sucedió sabemos que miles de personas
fueron asesinadas y torturadas
desgarradas y violadas y asesinatos de
niños
el presidente de eeuu joe biden acusó de
nuevo a su homólogo ruso vladimir putin
de ser un criminal de guerra
ustedes recordarán que fui criticado por
llamar criminal de guerra a vladimir
putin bueno vi lo que pasó en ducha esto
lo justifica es un criminal de guerra
washington pedirá a la asamblea general
de la onu que suspenda a rusia del
consejo de derechos humanos por su parte
de los rusos por intermedio del ministro
de relaciones exteriores insisten en que
es según ellos un montaje de ucrania
el ejército ruso se retiró por completo
de esta ciudad el 30 de marzo el 31 de
marzo el alcalde de la ciudad de bullas
declaró solemnemente que todo estaba en
orden dos días después vimos cómo se
organizaba esta puesta en escena en la
calle y como ahora están tratando de
usarla con fines anti rusos
mientras que la organización human
rights watch investiga en el terreno los
posibles crímenes
había un cuerpo que estaba aquí y estoy
tratando de buscar cualquier evidencia
física de cómo fue asesinado de donde
fue asesinados
y
lo que estamos viendo en el suelo aquí
son algunos casquillos de balas y
diseños
respuesta a alemania expulsará a 40
diplomáticos rusos de la embajada de
berlín francia tomará la misma medida
contra 35 funcionarios de la embajada de
rusia en territorio galo entre otros
habíamos de tema faltan seis días para
la primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en francia y el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón urgió
a los ciudadanos a salir a votar el
próximo domingo 10 de abril a medida que
se estrecha la diferencia en los sondeos
entre él y la ultraderechista marine
lepén el presidente manuel macrón sigue
liderando las encuestas con un 26.5 por
ciento de favorabilidad le sigue el epen
con un 23 por ciento
jean-luc mélenchon con 17 por ciento y a
él le siguen otros candidatos como
valerie pécresse y eric se move a pesar
de que el mandatario encabeza la lista
del apoyo en conjunto hacia los
aspirantes conservadores es mucho mayor
y de cara a la primera vuelta de las
elecciones de france 24 hemos preparado
una serie de reportajes sobre los
asuntos en juego la emigración parecía
ser el centro del debate la campaña pero
ahora está eclipsada por la guerra en
ucrania sin embargo no deja de ser una
de las prioridades ángela gutiérrez nos
cuenta que proponen los aspirantes
francia vive hoy una inmigración sin
precedentes actualmente hay 7 millones
de inmigrantes el 10 3 por ciento de la
población total la cifra más alta el
número y porcentaje de la población que
el país ha registrado que proponen los
candidatos para enfrentar este desafío
referéndum 10 de los 12 candidatos
quieren hacer esta consulta sobre los
temas clave del país incluida la
migración pero dos se focalizan en el
tema tanto marín depende el partido
reagrupación nacional como eric fémur
del partido la reconquista ambos de
extrema derecha proponen un referendo
para ponerle fin al reagrupamiento
familiar y al derecho europeo por encima
del francés además de endurecer el
acceso a la nacionalidad reformular el
control de las fronteras y la creación
por parte de ese muro del ministerio de
la emigración para expulsar a un millón
de extranjeros derecho de asilo todos
los candidatos quieren garantizarlo pero
con ajustes el presidente candidato de
manuel macrón de la república en marcha
quiere facilitar la expulsión de las
personas a las que se les haya negado
asilo y mantener las cuotas de
inmigrantes una reforma en su mandato
que para muchos fue un giro a la derecha
de su política migratoria
lepe en ese muro y la candidata
conservadora valérie pécresse de los
republicanos quieren que todas las
solicitudes se hagan desde el exterior
expulsión de condenados extranjeros
cinco de los doce candidatos manifiestan
en sus programas estar de acuerdo con la
expulsión de delincuentes extranjeros la
pnp cres macrón y se murió este último
propone expulsar también a los fichados
como radicales islamistas lucha contra
el islam radical y el terrorismo macro
mantiene la idea del cierre de
asociaciones y mezquitas radicales y en
firme la llamada ley contra el
separatismo aprobada en su quinquenio la
misma que quiere derogar el candidato de
izquierda jean luc mélenchon de la
francia insumisa por considerarla anti
republicana y tildada por le ven como
insuficiente ella prohibirá de raíz la
práctica y la difusión pública de la
ideología islamista
quienes entran a francia y quienes no un
desafío en las propuestas de los
candidatos que tratan de responder a
este fenómeno migratorio al que ahora se
suma la ola de refugiados ucranianos
cambiamos de tema y hacemos un resumen
de las principales noticias orrico 19
esta jornada uruguay dice que pondrá fin
a la emergencia sanitaria declarada hace
dos años cuando se detectaron los
primeros casos del nuevo coronavirus en
el país uruguay es uno de los menos
golpeados por el virus en américa
latina' registra una de las mayores
tasas de vacunación
en su intención por recuperar el turismo
cuba ya no exigirá una prueba negativa
de hobby 19 o certificado de vacunación
a los viajeros que deseen ingresar a la
isla la decisión obedece en parte según
las autoridades a los niveles de
inmunización alcanzados cuba registra la
tasa de vacunación más alta de américa
latina y el caribe a las vacunas
desarrolladas por su propia comunidad
científica
shanghai extenderá el confinamiento
impuesto a sus 26 millones de habitantes
mientras analiza los resultados de las
pruebas realizadas en una masiva campaña
para contener el brote de kobe 19 la
metrópolis china podría enfrentar el
peor brote de coronavirus que ha habido
desde que empezó la pandilla
y se agota el tiempo para actuar frente
al calentamiento global el grupo
intergubernamental de expertos sobre el
cambio climático publicó un informe
alertando de que al ritmo actual la
temperatura del planeta aumentará 3,2
grados este siglo un dato mucho más
preocupante del objetivo que se marcaron
los países en la última cumbre del clima
y que puso como límite no superar los 15
grados
un hallazgo alarmante la tierra puede
aumentar de temperatura 32 grados para
2100 si no se toman medidas urgentes así
lo determinó el informe del grupo de
expertos sobre cambio climático de
naciones unidas cuyas previsiones son
las más pesimistas hasta ahora aunque
dice que el planeta aún puede corregir
el rumbo en la cob 26 en glasgow los
países reafirmaron los compromisos
climáticos de la cumbre de parís para no
superar el calentamiento global por
encima de 1,5 grados sin embargo la
perspectiva es mucho más grave ya que
estamos en un camino hacia el
calentamiento global de más del doble
del límite de 15 grados acordado en
parís algunos líderes gubernamentales y
empresariales están diciendo una cosa
pero haciendo otra en pocas palabras
están mintiendo y los resultados serán
catastróficos esta es una emergencia
climática los científicos del clima
advierten que ya estamos peligrosamente
cerca de punto de inflexión que podrían
conducir a impactos climáticos en
cascada e irreversibles cascada
para alcanzar el objetivo y evitar un
desastre mayor las emisiones netas
globales deberán reducirse un 43% para
4 en 2050 unos datos que son alcanzables
si se adoptan medidas urgentes y el
informe dice que el mundo aún está
tiempo el gran mensaje que tenemos que
saber es que las actividades humanas nos
metieron en este problema y que la
acción humana puede volver a sacarnos de
él y creo que este es el mensaje
esperanzador que tratamos de transmitir
en este informe no está todo perdido
realmente tenemos la oportunidad de
hacer algo la apuesta por la energía
solar y eólica la restauración de los
bosques el cambio de dieta y la renuncia
a los combustibles fósiles están entre
las soluciones que proponen los expertos
en cualquier caso el futuro del planeta
sigue estando en manos de los líderes de
esta generación hasta aquí esta
informativa en france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]